قوه الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا يظهره
حال هذا الطريق بمدخل قريه جسر الحديد
تصدع كبير اصابه الى درجه نزوله
عن سطح الارض بحوالي متر وانزياحه ايضا
شمالا بنسبه كبيره السلطات التركيه قامت
بترميم جزء من هذا الطريق لفك العزله عن
سكان القريه الهادئه الواقعه قرب الحدود
السوريه صار يهزنا اشكال والوان يعني
ظل يتحولي شويه يعني نحن قلنا الارض طريق
كان عالي على تحت سلق اكثر من مترين لتحت
عن الجسر الحديد جواده الضيعه كلنا نزلت
على العاص
اودي البيوت كلهن بقوموا هاي الهوا
بينزلوا ويقوموا بينزلوا البيوت وبعدين
راعوا هيك فوق العاص النهر يعني راحوا
النهر 30 متر من هون هيك راحوا للنهار
سكروا النهر وبعد الماي شو اقول لك ايه
يابا وعلوان يابا بيتي مو مهدود ضحك
شقيت وجعت وحريت وظليت كم سنه من دون بيت
كم سنه ظليت سويت هالبيت هذا سويته والله
ما هلالي يابا ما قعدت بيه
الى نصفين بفعل قوه الزلزال الذي ضرب
المنطقه الجزء ناحيه النهر جرف معه قرابه
عشره منازل نجا سكانها باعجوبه من تحت
انقاذها فيما يقاوم هذا الجزء الانجرافات
التي سببها هذا الزلزال بعمق يزيد عن
ثلاثه مترات مخاوف اهالي هذه القريه لم
تتبدد بعد استمرار الهزات الارتداديه خوفا
من ان تشمل ما تبقى من اجزاء قريتهم عبد
القادر خربوش لقناتي العربيه والحدث من
قريه جسر الحديد على الحدود التركيه
السوريه